shannon purser it's so good to see you
variety power of young hollywood event
how are you feeling tonight i'm feeling
great it's actually so cool to see all
these people that i admire and i've ran
into some friends here too so yeah good
amazing you know we first fell in love
with you you know when barb the barbara
you're gonna be so cool now it's
ridiculous no i'm not
you better still hang out with me that's
all i'm saying
she had a short-lived run on the show
are you still watching stranger things
do you keep up with the show yeah i'm
definitely caught up i see all the memes
um it's really exciting i have like a
little sister who watches the show so
it's just it's just fun yeah
what do you make of this most recent
season because it was wild absolutely
wild but i love like the new the new
cast members the new characters they
introduced were really great and
um i don't know i'm just i'm wondering
how next season can get any stranger but
i guess we will find out
you know what the fans want as the show
comes to a close we're hoping that we
get some form of justice for barb is
there a chance we might see you pop up
not that i know of but i feel like
anything could happen so who knows would
you be down oh absolutely yeah it'd be
so fun okay good what would you want to
see happen what does justice for barb
look like in your brain i mean i feel
like she's gotten a lot of justice but
like honestly it'd be so fun if she were
the monster like i would love for her to
come back and like take her revenge i
think that would be really fun oh my
gosh well are you still in touch with
the cast can you put the buzz in their
ear oh i don't know i every now and then
i mean we definitely like keep in touch
with social media and stuff but they're
they're a very busy group of group of
kids for sure you're so great on
riverdale too when riverdale and
rivervales split it was supposed to be
a clean break between the universes
but clearly there's there's been a bleed
another show that's kind of coming to an
end we're about to tie a ribbon around
it what are your hopes as we go into
this final season of riverdale
i think what i appreciate about
riverdale is that they pull out like all
the stops um every season is like more
kooky than the last and i feel like
i'm just always so interested to see
what they come up with so i feel like
the season will be even more extreme
okay but what does that mean for ethel
who knows i mean she hasn't been like
killed off yet so she is still around
technically
um i'm not sure what that means for her
but i would be down for whatever i've
already like saved the world twice i
think so i could do that again
yeah
you know i think you have some sort of
like magic about you because you've been
attached to these two shows that just
have so much love and fandom behind it
as you think about like the next chapter
of shannon purser what does that look
like
um honestly i'd really love to be on the
creative side of things i'm working on a
project right now that i can't talk
about but i love writing yeah and i
would love to make some opportunities
for myself and for other people i love
horror and like genre stuff so
yeah something in that vein would be
really fun okay you love horror she said
it right here we need you on the finale
of stranger things yeah let's do it you
and becna just terrorizing all of us
[Music]
you